ambushed on a desolate road at night
andrew repels a coyote attack
but the coyote isn't alone
as soon as i hit the
initial
coyote on the head with the flashlight
that's when the other two
you know saw the aggression from me and
and started to attack
it was overwhelming
i figured that hitting the first one it
would have been done but it wasn't all
it did was made it worse
andrew is now under attack by three
coyotes a pack
this is a species that has evolved
this kind of pattern this behavioral
pattern of increased hunting success
when you're in a pack if coyotes are in
a pack they have the ability to bring
down quite large prey including
hooved animals like white-tailed deer
and even humans but overall given the
number of humans and given the number of
coyotes it's still a very rare
phenomenon why would a group of coyotes
attack a human is a bit of a mystery
at that point it was just mayhem in mind
that it's it's three four o'clock in the
morning and the only thing i can i
really see is a general outline of the
animal and and just the shimmer of the
light of the eyes humans we are not as
well equipped as coyotes are at night
they can see better they they have eye
shine this reflective iridescent set of
cells in the back of the retina that
serve to capture light and then bounce
that light back out
so that then the optic nerve ultimately
is picking up on the the light
information so they see a lot better
all i could think about was i needed
both hands i couldn't do anything with
the flashlight imagine like having three
or four people just in your face so i
dropped the flashlight and i just put my
hands up at first i wasn't even actually
trying to hurt them because i know that
wildlife is territorial and i you know
i'm just trying to get away from where
it started and they're essentially just
kicking up off of my waistline trying to
get up and higher
by far and away the most vulnerable
aspect of any vertebrate
is the neck and the head
that's where the brain is that's where
eyes that's where the very anatomy of of
respiration is taking place so
ultimately in bringing down a prey
species they want to go for that region
of the body
the only thing i really could do was
keep myself from falling down and making
sure that they didn't get behind me
after a while it really started to hurt
there were gases on my arms they were
essentially just opening up the wounds
mooring one tactic that coyotes used was
just to get lots of little bites and the
prey starts bleeding out
really all i could process at that
moment was keep one foot in the dirt and
one foot on the pavement i don't want to
lose any kind of advantage that i had in
this situation but when the adrenaline
started to wear off i did start to get
tired and the pain started to set in it
was starting to get to the point where i
felt like i had no control of the
situation and that they were starting to
get the upper hand
[Music]
you